hey 42 here human beings have adapted
the world around us to suit our needs it
is our intelligence that allowed us to
learn tool building agriculture and
language and so become far more advanced
than any of our fellow creatures but
that's not to say that some animals
don't have wonderful abilities and
tricks up their sleeves that we can only
begin to marvel at thanks to the work of
medical science and nutrition we are
living longer and longer with life
expectancy increasing by one year every
5 years we are able to survive some
pretty extreme places on earth but we
have nothing on a little guy called a
tardigrade
also known as water bears or the super
cute named moss piglets these segmented
micro animals are typically 0.5
millimeters in length and can be found
in virtually every environment in the
world their ability to survive is to be
honest
utterly ridiculous they are the supermen
of the animal kingdom if Superman was a
tiny eight-legged bear made of pillows
think Canada is cold
well these bad boys can manage it - 272
degrees Celsius that's only one degree
above absolute zero where everything
right down to the atomic level stops
moving of course they don't just put on
a hat and get on with their shopping
they are in a state of cryptobiosis
that's like the deep hibernation that
you see in sci-fi films and they can
only last at these levels for a few
minutes but bring the heat back up and
they'll be out and about again getting
up to mischief if they fancy a bit of so
NASA winter snooze then you can crank it
up all the way up to 150 degrees Celsius
and they'll still be knocking back the
margaritas as though nothing has
happened they can take pressures six
times what you'd find at the bottom of
our deepest ocean and it can handle
doses of ionizing radiation so high not
just a fraction of a percent of it would
turn us into dribbling mutants whilst
our cells collapse
they can even survive in space for
almost two weeks and can survive without
food or water
for over 30 years they would probably
prefer not to them but if you want real
immortality then scientists are now
looking at the Scarlet jellyfish its
gelatinous body may not offer much
protection but it has an incredible
trick if it does get injured it sinks to
the seafloor and returns to its juvenile
state called a polyp from here it will
grows back to an adult jellyfish with a
slate wiped clean effectively granting
it biological immortality the whole
process takes about two months so maybe
one day if you break a leg or two you
just have to pop back to kindergarten
for a few semesters whilst you
regenerate it might help improve your
terrible handwriting as well when we
think about light we think about what we
can see but the visible spectrum is
actually a very small part of a much
wider range and even within the visible
spectrum our ability to separate colors
is actually quite limited in the back of
your eye the retina you process the
light through cells called
photoreceptors there are two main types
of these rods and cones the rods process
just black and white so they work very
well in low-light situation and they
make up most of your peripheral vision
you'll notice that you don't see much
color around the edges of your vision
you're doing it now on you you're trying
to look at the side of your eyes in the
middle of your retina where most of the
light comes in you have a higher
concentration of cone cells the cone
cells process color and there are three
types of them one for long medium and
short wavelengths this is all the color
basically is a different wavelength long
wavelengths are Reds medium are yellow
and green and short are blue the mantis
shrimp however has 12 different types of
cone cells if we had eyes like that we
will be able to see huge differences
between every single shade of color it
would make arguments over what color to
paint the bedroom lasts for a lifetime
it's bad enough that
in paint called elephant breath just
imagine if there were 46 different
shades of it but oddly shrimps color
perception is actually not much better
than our own since they don't have the
brainpower to decipher all that
information their amazing eyes just do
most of the work so their little brains
don't have to this is not the only quirk
of their evolution just like their
cousin the pistol shrimp they can punch
so rapidly with their claws that they
have been known to smash aquarium glass
finally on vision the pit viper may have
slightly worse call detection than we do
but they have evolved a brand new sense
of it between their eyes and their
nostrils that allows them to see
infrared light this means that they can
spot prey and be warned of predators no
matter how dark it gets the benefits of
technology mean that we can enhance or
replace many parts of our body but these
are all man-made these kind of mechanics
don't occur naturally do them well this
is the Issus Cleopatra's it's a small
plant sucking book and it has evolved
functioning mechanical gears this allows
it to jump extremely rapidly it may only
move at 5 meters per second but it
accelerates in under and milliseconds at
a force of over 500 G's to give you some
context 1g is the normal gravity you
feel on earth an astronaut leaving earth
experiences 3 G's
so what is the point of these biological
cogs what purpose do they achieve well
the power comes from both legs and it's
such an incredible rate that if there
was a tiny difference between them it
would be impossible to control a
direction imagine if astronauts are in a
rocket with two engines and each were
firing at different power levels houston
we have a problem so to ensure that's
the clear Patras aren't constantly
crashing into walls and putting people
in bars or accidentally committing
suicide the gear
adds two perfectly synchronize their
leaves the cogwheel turtle also has an
obvious gear shape that has grown
naturally but this has no mechanical
purpose it just looks like he's listened
to too much Marilyn Manson look at this
guy I know where are his legs they're
completely invisible now I know our
level of camouflage is pretty lame but
there are creatures out there that can
change shape and color in an almost
magical sort of way firstly there is a
chameleon of course everyone's favorite
hide-and-seek contestant they can change
color and patterns in order to send
messages such as aggression or
submission as well as camouflage result
they sometimes use it as a way of
controlling the heat they absorb - how
does it work we used to think that they
just had amazing control over the color
pigments in their skin but it turns out
to be fast smarter than that in the past
couple of years we have discovered that
one of the layers of their skin is made
up with a lattice of crystals called
guan e we all contain guanine as it is a
nitrogen based compound that is one of
the bases of DNA and RNA so pretty
important stuff chameleons can stretch
this lattice layer so it reflects light
differently when the lattice is excited
it stretches and this reflects longer
wavelengths such as yellows oranges and
reds in a relaxed state however it
reflects two shorter wavelengths the
blues and greens their skin also has a
yellow pigment which is why their base
color is often green since the relaxed
lattice gives off blues and this mixes
with the yellow pigment to create green
afar pretty of color changing animal is
the golden tortoids beetle they look
like jewelry most of the time but not
only is their metallic gold coloring
pretty spectacular they are very rare in
the insect world as they can change
color the Lay's of their shells contain
nano groups that are normally filled
with a light red liquid that gives them
their golden shine when this liquid is
drained the lower darker red layers
become visible
so when you watch them they turn from
gold to red this happens when they are
agitated and often during sex just like
us humans but it's believed you have
another benefit red shelled books like
lady Birds or ladybugs in the US aren't
popular food for birds
so maybe the golden tortoids beetles are
mimicking this to avoid being blunt even
their gold color could make them hard to
spot as the bright reflection would
throw off their avian enemies now color
is one thing but the mimic octopus can
transform its whole body to look like a
wide range of other local creatures it
impersonates sea snakes and jellyfish
amongst other things so that its
predators avoid it and it also uses
impersonation to catch its own food
sometimes walking like a crab so that it
can attract a mate and then pouncing on
it before the crab realizes it's too
late aquatic tinder is a scary place
free free drink tomorrow okay but
promise me you're not secretly an
octopus opossums find the world in
general a pretty scary place which is
why they are famous for fauna ptosis or
playing dead to you and me but when real
danger strikes they have a nifty little
trick of their scruffy little sleeves
opossums can immunize themselves against
toxins such as snake venom and plants
things they produce a protein called the
lethal toxin neutralizing factor el TNF
for short that does exactly what its
name suggests neutralizes toxins for
snakebites this means that they can
counteract both the part that stops your
heart and the hemorrhaging part which
makes you keep on bleeding for humans
the current way of dealing with a
snakebite is through antivenoms you have
to take a sample of each specific
snake's venom and then inject a small
dose of it into another animal such as a
goat or a horse then we can extract a
serum and use it to fight the poison
when a human is bitten
this procedure is far from perfect as
you need to keep a wide range of
different antivenoms and often these
days there are only captive major
hospitals and they may be wrong but you
probably won't get attacked by a snake
in a
they're more of an outdoorsy type so
naturally research into the opossums
protein could be very valuable as it's
already been shown that mice can be
injected with it and developed similar
self immunization skills to the opossum
a human ready version may not be so far
away let's just hope it doesn't make us
all play dead too
the streets will be littered with people
falling over every time a car horn
sounds self immunization is one thing
but our next creature takes it to a
whole new level this baby face little
salamander is called the axolotl and it
has an astonishing ability to regenerate
whole parts of its body again and again
many of a salamander types have some
regeneration ability such as their tails
but these guys can grow back whole legs
spines and even parts of their brain and
there's not even any scarring it's just
like me loading from a save point in a
video game lost you're like in a bike
accident no problem just reboot there
are also over 1000 times more resistant
to cancer than mammals are so they're a
pretty healthy bunch they also never
smoke and only drink in moderation there
is actually a reason for that baby's
face though they are one of a few unique
species that exhibit neoteny this means
that they don't go through a change to
reach adulthood or sexual maturity to be
more precise most animals have a
metamorphosis that changes their shape
coloring and physical characteristics a
human adult isn't just an inflated baby
the proportions are all different the
head shrinks in comparison to the body
limbs lengthen body hair grows and so on
the same is true for most species just
look at tadpoles becoming frogs larvae
becoming flies and seahorses growing
into full-sized horses now I'm not sure
about that last one actually but the
axolotl stays the same it just gets
larger most salamanders leave the water
and grow fully developed lungs but the
axolotl stays in the water and that
pretty frill around its neck
is it skills they do have rudimentary
lungs what they don't really use them
the scientists have found that you can
induce a change into adulthood in
axolotls where they become terrestrial
salamanders it's done by injecting
iodine into their fibroid gland whereas
as humans are forced to grow up by being
sent to our rooms are not allowed to
have any ice cream what ability do you
think ties all of these animals together
any guesses are they super fast super
smart do they look good in denim are
they great at doing Sudoku give up well
their special skill is electroreception
they have the ability to detect
electrical fields and to use them as a
sense much like we use hearing and
vision
it's almost exclusive to aquatic animals
since water especially saltwater is a
far better conductor than air but bees
do use electrical fields and charge in a
very unique way plants are usually
negatively charged and bees can become
very positively charged we've seen them
produce voltages of 450 volts during
tests this happened because they collide
with dust particles and small molecules
as they fly through the air the
collisions knock away electrons and lead
positively charged particles stuck to
the big their waxy cuticles are very
well insulated meaning that they can
build up a surprising amount of charge
this creates certain benefits firstly
they become stickier since they attract
the negatively charged pollen particles
but incredibly they also develop a
communication with the plants and we
believe that they can read which flowers
have recently been visited by other bees
due to the change in their electric
field
it's basically floral advertising so
bees can bumble around looking in the
shop windows to find out what they want
without having to go into every store
and the electro B magic doesn't end
there
Ave gregor's a neurobiologist from the
Free University of Berlin has been
studying the famous bee dance we've
known about their little waggle since
the 1920s but Gregor's now
things that the bees are actually
creating a change in the electric field
which other bees read through their
antennae right now all we know is that
they can do this we don't know for sure
if they really do they're done still
remains a mystery the platypus is part
of a group of egg-laying mammals called
monotremes and they are the only
creatures in the entire class known to a
lecture locate aside from one species of
Dalton
these weird little duck-faced otter
monsters close their eyes and ears when
they dive and they use its electrical
sense to detect the electric current
producing the muscles of its prey this
is why their heads sweep from side to
side like a sensor they also have ankle
Spurs that produce venom when you
combine it with their egg-laying it
seems like someone got very confused
when they were putting the Platypus
together and just grabbed whatever parts
they could find with all these amazing
abilities you might be sitting there
feeling jealous if the animal kingdom
and all its wonders why can't we jump
like lightning heal ourselves and see in
the dark it's just not fair so to make
yourself feel better go play on your
iPad loudly in front of your hamster and
tell him that he can't have a go because
he's stupid thanks for the view
subscribe for more 42
you